You know what I'm a big fan of? Atom-atons, you know, self-thinking robots
running around doing chores and all that stuff. Of course, if they have the
ability to think for themselves, they're probably going to get into some
trouble? Nah, we'll worry about that later. Anyhow, entities are a fantastic
concept, attaching logic to units is the backbone about how your simulation is
going to exist. Now, don't get too far down the rabbit hole here, entities
bridge the line between design and code. So, at every step of the way, when you
add features, you're going to have to negotiate between how much of the control
is on the designer side and on the programmer side. So, make sure when you're
designing your framework, keep both parties involved.